The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
So a little bit
of housekeeping
before we continue.
First of all, you
may have noticed
that in the reading
assignments, I have started
Boston from Goodman's book.
So there is some pros
and cons about this.
Goodman is very good if you
are an engineer, especially
electrical or
mechanical engineer.
Because then you are very used
to thinking about systems,
block diagrams,
transforms, and so on.
So it is very nice
living this way.
But it's a little
bit mathematical.
Hecht is more on
the physics side.
So I feel Hecht is written for
junior or sophomore physics
students.
And, of course, they're
very nicely complimentary.
The only real downside is that
they use different notation.
So if you tried Stanley
from both Hecht and Goodman,
you have to be a
little bit careful
to keep their notation--
I mean, the notation
is not consistent,
but you have to keep yourself
from getting confused
by the inconsistent notation.
Nevertheless, the diagrams
are, of course, consistent
because they both
calculate the same.
Fresnel, the fraction
pattern is the same
from [INAUDIBLE]
pattern and so on.
But you have to be a little
bit mindful of the coordinates.
For example, they may be
using different symbols.
Anyway, I highly
recommend that you're
starting from both books.
Hecht also has a much more
intuitive explanations,
and many more
figures, and so on.
But Goodman is more
rigorous, and also better
suited to an engineer's
way of thinking.
So that's why I
use both textbooks.
By now, it's actually closer
to Goodman from this point on.
So that's an additional benefit.
Anyway, the reading assignments
are from both books.
If you decide to
follow just one book.
For example, either Hecht by
itself or Goodman by itself.
You don't miss significantly,
you can follow either book.
But I think until you get the
complete picture, if you follow
both books and in the way they
serve to reinforce each other.
Anyway, so that's the
study about the textbooks.
A little bit more housekeeping.
I have posted the
slightly revised
version of Monday's notes.
One minor correction,
if you look at this.
This is the very last
slide from Monday.
There was an error, at
least one that they found.
In the expression for the
Fourier coefficient c sub q,
it was the function
sinc of 2 over 2.
This is correct.
On Monday, there was an
extra pi inside the argument
of the same function.
That pi should not have been
there, so I've removed it.
We will see today later the
derivation of this expression,
actually, a similar expression.
So hopefully, that
will clarify matters.
The thing I did
compare to Monday.
Piper reminded me on Monday,
when he discussed the grading,
about the dispersion.
So if you look at the--
go back a little bit
to the expressions,
or the diffraction
angle from a grating.
OK, that's a good one.
OK, so last week, we
focused on a discussion
about the effect of the period.
So we said that if you
make the period smaller,
the diffraction order
is spread out more,
so the diffraction
angle is inversely
proportional to the period.
Actually, the sine of
the diffraction angle.
We didn't say anything
about wavelength.
So, of course, the wavelength
appears in the numerator
there, which means that if you
have light of multiple colors,
then longer wavelengths will
focus at the longer angle.
So this is what you
see on the last slide
that they posted today
in the revised notes.
So I have a grating here which
is illuminated by white light.
So, of course, white
light is composed
of a broad spectrum
of colors ranging
from somewhere in the
infinite to somewhere
in the ultraviolet.
Anyway, let's take
the discussion.
Let's keep it to the
visible wavelength.
So, of course, the red
wavelength has a longer color.
I'm sorry, the red color
has a longer wavelength.
So therefore, the red color
is diffracted at the larger
angle than the blue.
So this phenomenon is called
dispersion, very similar
to the grating dispersion.
But it is referred to
as anomalous, because it
is the opposite of the grating.
I'm sorry, it is the
opposite of a prism.
What am I saying?
Let me start over.
So in the case of
a prism, as well as
in the case of a
grating, the phenomenon
of analysis of
white light, where
white light after propagating
through the element gets
decomposed into its
color component.
And each one color
component propagates
at the different angle.
This phenomenon is
referred to as dispersion.
If the two are different
in the sense that
in the case of a
grating, the blue light
is refracted at the smaller
angle than the red light.
That is called the
normal dispersion.
In the case of a prism, it
is not diffraction anymore.
It is refraction.
And we saw why it happens.
This has to do
with the dependence
of the index of refraction
of glass on wavelength.
And the dependence is
such that the blue light
is refracted at the larger
angle, in the case of a prism.
That is called normal
dispersion, as opposed
to the anomalous.
Now, there is nothing anomalous
about the grating, I suppose.
Historically, this had
to do with the fact
that people observed this
phenomenon with prisms first,
so they call it
normal dispersion.
Then they noticed
that the grating
does the opposite thing, so they
said, well, this is abnormal.
They called it anomalous.
Anomalous in Greek
means abnormal.
Anyway, so this is what I wanted
to add to Monday's lecture.
Are there any questions
about gratings?
Actually, between today
and next Wednesday,
we will cover the basics
of diffraction theory.
And the rest of
the class will be
basically applications
on what we
cover in these three lectures.
So needless to say,
these three lectures
are very, very important.
So let us start with a little
observation on our Fresnel
propagation formula.
So to remind you very
briefly, today, I
will be using the
whiteboard a lot.
But the equations
that I write are all
of them, either in the
notes or in the textbooks.
So feel free to copy them if
you like, but you don't have to.
It may be better.
It's up to you whether you want
to copy the derivations or not.
But there will be a lot of them.
Probably by the
end of the lecture,
your wrist may be
a little bit tired.
OK.
So to remind you, we did
this about a week ago.
We said that if you have a
complex field at the plane xy,
and then you propagate
by a distance, z.
Then at the output
plane x prime, y prime,
the field is given by
this convolution integral,
which I will rewrite here.
So the field at the output
after propagating by distance z
equals some constants--
and we'll spend
some time talking
about these constants--
times what we'll
call the convolution integral.
So the convolution integral
is really written something
like this, e to the i pi.
OK, so this is the integral
within the Fresnel and scalar
approximations.
Then what we can do is we can--
let's take this
exponent, and expand it.
So I will only do
it for the x case.
That's not rocket science.
They've just expanded
the binomial.
Now, let me remind you.
So the x prime coordinate
is at the output plane.
And also, you can see that
it is not participating
in the integration.
The integration is
with respect to x.
So the x prime
part will actually
be thrown out of the integral.
And then I have
this remaining part.
So the next thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to assume that
the input field is finite.
So finite means that the field,
if you look at the input field
here.
The field is non-zero in
a relatively small region
near the optical axis.
But then away from the optical
axis, the field becomes zero.
That is a reasonable
assumption, because most objects
that we're going to create
in real life are finite.
We've said this before, I think.
We deal with things
like plane waves
and spherical waves in this
class, which are infinite.
But these are idealizations
that we use in order
to make the math simpler.
In this case, let's use actually
a real life assumption, which
is that the object is finite.
And since the
object is finite, x
will be confined to
relatively small values.
So what I will do now is I
will look at this expression, x
prime over lambda z.
This is this part
of the exponent.
And what I will do now is I will
allow z to become very large.
So what does this mean?
It means that I
start propagating
further and further and further
away from the transparency.
Of course, x is limited by
the size of the input field.
So x square is also
limited, but z grows
as I propagate further away.
So there will come a point
where x square maximum
will become less than lambda z.
That is, the maximum value
of this fraction over here
will become less than one.
And in fact, if I keep
propagating further
and further, this
term will actually
grow less and less and less.
OK, if that is the case,
then the coefficient--
then this term over here
will become negligible,
which means that I can drop it.
OK, so this is what is written
in your transparency over here.
Basically, I actually did
this for both x and y.
I pulled out the
x prime, y prime.
And I'm left with this
expression over here.
So let me also do it
on my whiteboard here.
So what I'm saying
is that the g out.
In the whiteboard, I will
not write the y-coordinates,
because it is too much.
Well, maybe I write
them to avoid confusion.
OK, so this will
now take this form.
This got pulled
out of the integral
because they don't participate
in the integration.
And then what I have
inside looks like this.
And what I was saying
is that if I let z
become long enough,
then it can basically
neglect those two terms.
Now, why do I neglect
only these two terms,
and not the products of y over
y times y prime and x times
x prime.
Why should they keep
those two terms?
And, of course, I forgot
something in both cases.
In here, I should have
g sub in of x comma y,
and the same in here.
OK, you see what I did?
Over here, I need to put the
input field, and the same here.
So why am I keeping this term,
and I am not dropping it?
If I drop it, it's
very easy, right?
If I drop it altogether,
then what I will get
is the integral of g sub in.
It's like the
average of the input.
Why am I not doing that?
AUDIENCE: If you
remove the cross term,
then we actually neglect the
complete spatial variation
of the input field,
and it becomes
like a pointed [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
So I would actually
disagree with that.
If I neglect it, I will get
that g sub out of x comma
y prime equals g sub
in of x comma y dx, dy.
So this is a constant, right?
It is like the
average of g sub in.
So I haven't really
neglected it.
I have said that it gets
averaged out at the output.
And by the way, that's wrong.
That's not true, right?
This is a wrong result.
My question is
why is that wrong?
Why do I have to keep
the entire formula,
z out of x prime, y prime, z.
Let me write it properly now.
So the question is why can
I neglect the quadratics,
but I must keep the cross terms?
Actually a very simple answer.
All you have to
do is look at it.
AUDIENCE: Does it mean you
are restricting the output
field to a limited area?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
If you look at
these cross terms,
they actually depend on the
output coordinate, x prime.
I haven't made any
assumptions about x prime.
x prime can be as
large as I want.
So this term can actually
dominate the quadratic term.
That's the point.
This term, I can control by
making the input transparency
relatively small, and
making z arbitrarily large.
However, this term
has the x prime in it.
And x prime can be
actually very large itself.
So I can never
neglect this term.
That's the point
of this argument.
Everybody clear on that?
So if I indeed neglect this
term, then what I will get
is that g sub out--
I think this marker is dead, so
I'll move on to the next one.
It has some terms
which I will neglect,
but it is proportional to a
quantity that looks like this.
Which I can also rewrite as.
I didn't do anything.
All I did was I--
these parameters here, if
you look at this coefficient.
It does not depend on the
variable of integration.
Therefore, I can
call it something.
I call it u.
And this integral now.
It is probably familiar to you.
If it were in one dimension, it
would be immediately familiar.
It is a Fourier transform.
But it is in two dimensions,
so it appears a little bit more
complicated with two variables.
But actually, well, it is
a convention to write--
what happened here--
to write Fourier
transforms as uppercase.
So this is a g sub in of u
comma v. The Fourier transform
computed at frequencies.
Something magical happened
if I let the field propagate
at a relatively long distance.
They field that I get
at that output plane
actually equals
approximately the
Fourier transform of the input
field, which is interesting.
And we'll see a lot
of ramifications
of that in the next few hours.
OK, let's see this
now in a calculation.
Actually, Piper solved it
in practice, in real life.
Last time at the
demo, you actually
saw this kind of
thing happening.
What I will show
now is some movies
which are also posted
on the website,
so you can go back
and produce them.
So in the movie,
you will actually
see the Fourier transform
slowly developing.
In this case, it is a
rectangular aperture.
So the Fourier transform
is very easy to compute.
Of course, in the movie,
there's no Fourier transform.
In the movie, all I did is
I convolved with a Fresnel
propagation coordinate for
progressively longer distances.
And then I put all those frames
together, and I made the movie.
But you will see that
as z grows larger,
the aperture develops
a small oscillation.
But then eventually, it
develops this pattern that well,
it is called the sinc function.
And we'll see in a moment
that this is actually
the special Fourier
transform of that function.
Let me play that once again.
If you notice
carefully, you will
see that you start with a
nice, clear, sharp aperture.
As we will propagate,
first, we'll
see some diffraction ringing.
Professor Sheppard described
in detail last time.
But then this ringing slowly
gives away to this cross
like looking pattern.
So you can see it here.
It has a very distinct pattern.
It has a central lobe,
and then side lobes
expanding along the
x and y dimension.
OK, so what is this now,
and how did it come about?
This function, the aperture
that I started with.
I can describe it
mathematically as g sub
in of x comma y equals 1 if--
basically, let me go back.
So this function
equals 1 if x and y
are within this rectangle.
Mathematically, we can
describe this as x less
than the size of the
aperture, and y also
less than the size
of the aperture.
Generally, it may be a
rectangle, not a square.
So use the different variables.
And it is zero otherwise.
OK, so it is convenient
to define a function.
And actually, I goofed.
If the size of the
aperture is x over naught,
then the value of the function
is 1 for x less than x0.
So I will explain
this in a second.
OK, so if I defined the
function rect this way.
So that's the function.
Sometimes, it's also
known as a boxcar.
And so this would be rect of x.
And if I went to plot
rect of x over x0,
then if I substitute
x over x0 0, 0 here.
Then it is 1 if x over
x0 is less than 1/2.
So basically, this extends from
minus x0 over 2 to x0 over 2.
And it equals the
value 1 over there.
And therefore, the total size of
the boxcar is x0 as advertised.
OK, and, of course, if I define
the rect function this way,
then my original
function, g sub in.
I can simply write it as
was done here, as a product.
So now, what is the Fourier
transform of that product?
Let me write it down to the
Fourier transform definition.
OK, that's the Fourier
transform definition.
The first thing that I
notice in this case, which
is very convenient, is that
the integral is separable.
I can write it, really, as
a product of two integrals.
One of them is in
the x dimension.
And the other looks very
similar in the y dimension.
This is not always the case.
Many, or actually, most 2D
functions are not like that.
But in this case, we're lucky.
Means you don't have
to do the whole thing.
We can just do the integral
for one coordinate,
and then we immediately have
the answer for the other
coordinate as well.
OK, so let's write it then.
So I will just write the
one dimensional integral.
OK.
So now, let's do one
more simplification.
I will assume that
x0 is unit, is unity.
We'll come back and
rectify this one.
But for now, I will
just assume it this way
to make my life a
little bit easier.
So if that is the
case, if x0 is one.
Then [INAUDIBLE] what is the
function rect of x over one.
It is this one over here.
So it is 0 outside,
and it is only 1
between x equals
minus 1/2 and 1/2.
So in that case,
then, the integral.
That's the integral.
Now, there's a simple
one to calculate.
I don't know how I
picked up a naught here.
This would not be no naught.
Drop this one.
Just e to the i to pi u, right?
Nothing here.
So I have u times 1/2 minus
e to the i 2 pi, u minus 1/2.
And these two minuses cancel.
And if I flip this
around, it is actually
the definition of a sine.
So this equals 1 over
minus i 2 pi u0, times
minus 2i sine of what was here.
The twos also cancel.
And I get pi u.
So finally, after dropping
the remaining constants.
I still got a u0.
There's no u0.
For some reason, my brain
puts a naught there.
There shouldn't be.
So after finally canceling
whatever is left,
I get sine of pi u over pi u.
OK, so that function, by
definition, is called a sinc.
And I'll jump ahead in
the naught a little bit.
You can also look it
up in the textbook.
The sinc function
looks like this.
It is in page--
I forget which page,
between page 12 and page 14
of the Goodman textbook.
This is the sinc function.
One argument equals 0.
2 and it has a peak and
then it kind of oscillates,
but the amplitude
of its oscillation
drops inversely proportional
to the argument.
So the oscillation
comes from the sine.
The inversely proportional comes
from the u in the denominator.
So this may be a little
bit boring for you.
For those of you who have
taken signal processing,
you're probably ready
to go to sleep now.
For reasons of completeness,
we have to do it,
to go through it.
Then I will not compute
too many Fourier integrals.
But in any case, if you are to
compute one Fourier transform,
that's the one to compute.
So that's it, then.
This is also the definition
of the original rect function
that we had.
And its Fourier transform
is the sinc function.
Now, we're not done yet, because
I made one more simplifying
assumption.
I said that x0 equals 1.
So what do we do about this x0?
Well, does anybody know
what I can do about this x0?
OK what I'll do is a
change of variable.
And I will do it in
the general case.
Let's say that
they have a G of u
equals the Fourier transform of
some general function, g of x.
So this is then the Fourier
transform of g of x.
What is the Fourier transform
of a scale version of g of x?
Well, that would be
something like this.
It would be from minus
infinity to infinity, g of ax,
e to the minus i two pi ux dx.
And to get rid of
this ugly thing here,
I can make a change
of coordinates.
For example, let's
say that c equals ax.
Then this means that
dx e equals a dx.
And I can write the integral.
So they actually
become dx e over a.
I pick up 1 over a out here.
Nothing happens to infinity.
It remains infinity.
This would be g of c, e
to the minus i two pi.
Now, x is also c upon a, big C.
I haven't cheated.
This is the transformed--
the integral.
So the 1 over a basically
keeps me honest here.
Makes sure that the area of
the differential is preserved.
It's also known as a Jacobian.
But anyway, that's what it is.
And I can do one more
little manipulation here.
I can rewrite it like this.
And we can recognize
now that this integral--
let me see if I can fit
them both on the screen.
OK, so recognize
that this integral
is the same as this
integral, except
with a different variable,
with a different argument.
So therefore, what I derived
here is one over a G of,
u over a.
OK, so this is a property
of Fourier transforms
known as the scaling theorem.
Or sometimes, people call
it the similarity theorem.
And let's see how we can apply
it to the question at hand.
We derived that the
rectangle function.
If you Fourier transform it,
you get the sinc function.
OK, what I really wanted to
get is the Fourier transform
of a rectangle,
which has a size, x0.
Now let me write down
the scaling theorem.
It says that g of ax
Fourier transforms to 1
over a G of u over a.
So in this case, a is
identical to 1 over x0.
So therefore, the
Fourier transform
will be x0, sinc of x0 times u.
And this is intuitively
satisfying because the units
here inside the sink.
The units are naught.
x0 has dimensions
of space, meters.
u is a frequency, so it has in
dimensions of inverse meters.
So therefore, what I
have inside the argument
has no dimensions at all,
which is, of course, of the way
it should be.
OK, so this is them.
So [INAUDIBLE]
for one last time.
This is how we obtain this
function with the central lobe.
But the side lobe is actually
not quite the sinc function
itself, because I'm
blocking the intensity here.
It is actually sinc squared.
But anyway, this is
where this came from.
So, of course, if you
multiply the two dimensions,
you get a sinc in
the x dimension,
and sinc in the y dimension,
and then, of course,
you get the product.
And the Fourier
transform theorem
says that the final field
will actually be the Fourier
transform, but with
the coordinate,
the special frequency
coordinate replaced
by x prime over lambda z.
This is where this came from.
I substituted u with
x prime over lambda z.
So the bottom line is that
this is perhaps easier
if you look at it heads up.
So here is a
rectangular function.
I only saw the x dimension
here with a size of x0.
Then you can see that
the Fourier transform.
Actually this square, the
intensity of the Fourier
transform.
It has this characteristic
sinc pattern
with a central lobe
and then side lobes.
And the size of the
central lobe is inversely
proportional to the
size of the rectangle.
So if I make this
rectangle smaller,
this size will become bigger.
So this is then our first
Fraunhofer diffraction pattern.
The Fraunhofer
diffraction pattern
of a rectangular function.
Of course, there is
many different apertures
that are of interest
in this business.
Oh, and this, by the way,
is called the sinc pattern,
as I already mentioned.
So there's many different
patterns of interest.
For example, very
often in optics,
we use circular apertures.
Lenses, irises, in cameras,
most optical systems
have a circular aperture.
In this case, we talked
about the blinking
or the Poisson spot here.
But that's not what
I'm interested now.
I'm interested in the far
field diffraction pattern.
And in this case, you also
get a pattern with a--
kind of looks like a sinc, but
a sinc with circular symmetry.
It is not exactly a sinc.
It is given by a rather
nasty formula here.
It is the ratio.
First of all, it is all
done in polar coordinates.
So you see that you
get the square root
of the sum of the Cartesian
coordinates squared.
But the function itself
is given by the ratio
of a Bessel function
of the first kind
and order 1 divided
by its argument.
I will not go into to the
detail of the derivation here.
Goodman describes
it in great detail.
So if you're interested, you can
go and check it out over there.
I do want to emphasize
a couple of things.
First of all, that is
this sometimes by analogy
to the sinc.
This pattern is
referred to as a jinc.
So the J comes, of
course, from the Bessel J.
So we call it a jinc function.
And more commonly it is
referred to as the Airy pattern.
Airy not because it sucks
air or something like that.
Actually, it is named after
someone, some Englishman,
whose name was Airy.
So Airy pattern.
And if you compare it
with the previous one.
The previous one.
I'm sorry, you have endure
this animation again.
OK, so the previous one.
The null actually occurred
that lambda l divided
by the size of the aperture.
In the case of the
jinc, there's a factor
of 1.22 that [INAUDIBLE]
the calculation.
So the null basically occurs
at the very similar looking
variable.
If you make the diameter
shorter, the size of the jinc
will grow.
But the null, the zero of the
jinc, occurs at this function,
at this value, 1.22,
which, of course, comes
from the zero of
the Bessel function.
So there's no intuition here.
It's just where this function
happens to reach value zero.
OK.
Let me skip this
slide, and perhaps you
can go over it and
talk about it later.
It basically elaborates a
little bit on the issue of--
I said before that in order
to observe the Fraunhofer
diffraction pattern, have
to let z become long enough.
Have to propagate
the field far enough.
So this slide answers the
question, well, how far is far?
Let me skip it four now.
And if we have time later,
I will come back to it.
But what I would like
to get started now
is a few comments on
Fourier transform the cells,
and how they apply to
different apertures.
So calling the Fourier transform
is a topic in applied math,
really.
I don't want to
convert this to 18085,
or whatever it is at MIT that
you'll learn those things.
But I will remind you of
some of the basic properties.
So one is the definition
of the Fourier transform.
I already wrote it down.
Many of you are more
familiar with the time domain
definition, where the
Fourier variable is actually
a frequency measured in hertz.
Of course, because here,
we're talking about signals
in the space domain.
The frequency variable
is the spatial frequency,
so the units are
actually inverse meters.
Hertz is inverse second.
The units here are
inverse meters.
And, of course,
because we're dealing
with two dimensional
special variables,
it is a two dimensional
Fourier transform because it
is a double integral.
But other than that,
it's very similar.
The other thing I
wanted to remind you
is that there is an inverse
Fourier transform which
looks very similar, except
for a minus sign, so
into the exponent here.
And, of course, the
inverse Fourier transform
takes you back to the
original function.
So it's like a dance.
You start with a
initial function.
You compute the
Fourier transform,
then you plug it into the into
the inverse Fourier transform,
and you get back
what you started.
That is sometimes referred to
as the Fourier integral instead
of an inverse Fourier transform.
So what is this really,
this Fourier transform?
If you look at its surreal
part, and if you have a real
function here.
Basically, what the
Fourier transform does
is it multiplies this function.
It is denoted as
red here, g of x.
It multiplies with a sinusoid.
The real part of this complex
exponential is a cosine.
So you multiply the
function with this cosine,
and then you integrate.
OK, so why do you do
something like that?
Actually, does anybody
know why Fourier came up
with this kind of transform?
What was the context
that Fourier--
what was Fourier?
Fourier was a French
mathematician,
or a French applied
physicist, I guess.
And he was trying to solve
a particular problem.
Does anybody know
what's the problem
he was trying to solve when
he came up with this business?
OK, it was a problem
of heat transfer.
Fourier was trying to
solve the problem of what
is that temperature distribution
between two hot plates, one
of them at temperature t1,
that at temperature of t2.
And actually, the answer is not
given by a Fourier integral.
It is given by a Fourier series.
And if you make the plates go.
If you increase the
distance between the plates,
the Fourier series
becomes an integral.
So this entire
mathematical arsenal here,
it actually came from the
field of heat transfer,
interestingly enough.
Anyway, that is of no
concern to us here.
The Fourier transform,
as many of you know--
especially those who
do acoustics or signal
processing-- it has
tremendous applications
in signal processing nowadays.
And, of course, it is still
used in heat transfer.
But in our context here, it
is more signal processing
that we will use it.
OK, so why do we
multiply by a sinusoid?
Well, the reason
is the following.
Suppose that G, our transformed
function, is itself a sinusoid.
OK, so here is G with a
particular frequency, u0.
So G is the red sinusoid.
The Fourier transform
kernel is another sinusoid.
And in general, they
have different frequency,
like shown here.
So what does the value
of this integral?
Do you know?
If the two frequencies
are different.
If you multiply two
sinusoids and integrate them
over a very long distance,
actually infinite.
Actually, by convention
in this class.
I don't know if I
mentioned it before.
The convention, if I don't
put bounds to an integral,
that mean it goes from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
So this is an infinite
integral of two sinusoids
with different
frequency multiplied.
What is the answer?
AUDIENCE: Zero?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Zero, yeah.
Because the various oscillations
that will cancel eventually.
So you'll get nothing.
OK, however, there's
a singular case when
the frequencies are the same.
And what is the value of
this integral in this case?
Well, infinite, right?
Because if you multiply
them, this will be positive.
This will also be positive,
because you are multiplying
two negative quantities.
So you actually get infinity,
which is not very good.
But in mathematics,
we have a way
of dealing with this kind
of abrupt infinities.
We call them delta functions.
And, of course, I'm severely
abusing the mathematics here.
The way the delta
function comes up.
Does anybody know?
It comes as a limit.
The way you get a
delta function is you
actually bound this integral,
so that you get a finite value.
And then you let the
bound go to infinity,
and the limit is
a delta function.
Anyway, without going into
these mathematical intricacies,
we can represent this
situation here as--
OK, forget for forget the second
delta function for a moment.
But this situation where
the value of the integral
is zero for all
frequencies except one.
Because the integral
assumes a huge value.
Then we write it as
a delta function.
And the why we get
two delta functions.
Well, we'll get
two delta functions
because the way this works
is if you take the Fourier
transform of an
exponential, this
is a single delta function.
Now, if you taking the cosine.
Of course, the cosine is a sum
of two complex exponentials.
And now we know how
to deal with this.
It's one of those that's given
by an expression like this one.
So you actually get two
symmetric delta functions.
OK, so what is
the one half here?
Well, the one half is
actually the energy contained
in this delta function.
So that's normal.
The thing is that is
a little bit weird
about this is that
this sort of situation
implies that there's such a
thing as negative frequency.
Of course, there's no
negative frequencies.
The frequencies can
only be positive.
The reason that we need
a negative frequency
is actually for
mathematical rigor,
because we insisted
on using phasors.
You remember a
long time ago, when
we started talking about waves.
We said that waves are
real, so they are actually
cosine functions.
But for mathematical
convenience,
in order to avoid complicated
trigonometric calculations,
it would represent
this cosine function
as a complex exponential.
Well, if you really had the
simple cosine transform.
So you use the cosine into
the kernel for the integral.
That is known as a
Fourier cosine transform,
and then it contains only
positive frequencies.
But it's nice to calculate.
Gives you very ugly formulas.
So that's why we'll use
the complex exponential.
It is simpler formulas,
but the price we pay
is this weird
negative frequency.
So there's nothing
to worry about.
It is not wrong
physics in any way.
It is simply a matter of
mathematical convenience
that leads to these
negative frequencies.
And, of course, I will not go
through all these derivations
over here.
But several functions,
their Fourier transforms
can be computed in
[INAUDIBLE] form.
In fact, all of these functions,
you can go ahead if you like,
and do the Fourier
transform by yourselves.
It is relatively simple
mathematical exercise.
So we will use some
of these very often.
Mostly, we'll use the
rectangular function.
I already talked about this one.
We'll use the circular function.
I talked a bit very briefly.
Then there is the
triangular function, which
has a shot of a grayscale.
It starts from zero, then
progressively it goes to one,
and then drops
back down to zero.
In linear fashion, and the com.
The composite sequence
of delta functions, that
is very useful in sampling.
I don't use it very much
in this class, actually.
I sort of bypass the
issue of sampling.
But I'm sure all of you are
familiar with Nyquist sampling
rates, Nyquist frequencies,
and so on and so forth.
So these all can be explained
by the com function.
And Goodman has a
section in the book.
I forget where it is.
It's a section two
point something.
Yeah, section 2.4, two
dimensional sampling
theory that goes over it.
I will not go over
it in the class.
But it may be good idea
for you to review it.
OK.
So as I said, there's
several functions here
who's Fourier transforms
can be computed.
I will not go through all of
these, but it is good for you
to know where this kind
of thing is in the book,
so when necessary,
you can refer to them,
and you can get the answers
for values [INAUDIBLE]..
So for example, here is
the rectangle function
that we computed before.
And, of course, it
gives the sinc response.
Another one worth remembering is
Gaussian, a Gaussian function.
Actually, also Fourier
transforms to Gaussian,
which is interesting.
And another useful one that
we will deal with later
is this one.
You should look at
them all before last.
It also looks like a
Gaussian, but with a J here.
So this we recognize.
Physically, what
is this function?
It is a complex
quadratic exponential.
Physically, what did we call it?
If I write it in a
slightly different form,
you will recognize
it right away.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: Spherical
wave along z?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
It is a spherical wave,
propagating a distance z.
So what you see over
there is actually
a spherical wave with a
slightly weird definition,
a squared equals
1 over lambda z.
So this expression here
in the row before last
is a spherical wave.
So a Fourier transform
is also a spherical wave.
And we will use this
Fourier transform quite
a bit in the next two lectures.
It might be good if you
start studying, by the way,
if you don't know what this is,
it means you haven't studied.
And I don't know how
you did the homework
without studying, possibly by
copying from the last year.
But I strongly
recommend that you
don't do that, because
you're presumably here
in order to learn.
And you don't learn
unless you study.
So it is about time, not
because of the quiz, but anyway.
The quiz is also coming
up, so it is about time
to start studying it.
So this is like a
friendly advice,
I guess, from an older guy.
Study.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE] that the
Fourier transform has.
Once we have this basic Fourier
transforms that are shown here,
then we can compute even
more Fourier transforms
by using the various properties
of the Fourier transform.
So one of those we
wanted to derive.
This is the scaling theorem.
I did this at the
beginning of the class.
And it tells you that if
you scale the argument that
goes inside the
Fourier transform,
then the Fourier transform
itself scales the opposite way.
So for example, in the case
of the Fraunhofer diffraction,
it says that if you make
an aperture smaller,
its Fraunhofer diffraction
pattern becomes larger.
So this is the scaling theorem,
physical and mathematical.
Physical, it tells you that
the Fraunhofer diffraction
becomes bigger.
Mathematically, it comes
from this scaling property
of the Fourier transforms.
Another important one is
the scaling theorem, which
will prove a little bit later.
But it's also very
important one.
Actually, all of these
properties are very important.
Number four is actually
energy conservation.
It relates the modulus--
the integral of the
modulus of a function.
We recognize this as energy.
If you look at number
four, magnitude g squared
is actually intensity.
And if you integrate intensity
over the entire plane,
then you'll get, of course,
energy flux, you get power.
And power has to be
conserved, so this
is what this theorem says, very
important, Parseval's theorem.
And the convolution theorem
is also very important.
We'll see an application
a little bit later today,
or maybe Monday if we
run out of time today.
But anyway, all of these
are very important.
OK, so I will show
you some Fourier
transforms to sort of give
you some of the properties.
Are we still on?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Thank you.
So this is a sinusoid.
Of course, this is not
a physical transparency.
Well, I can make a physical
transparency like this,
but this assumes
negative values, which
means that to make a physical
transparency like this one,
you would have to have
a phase delay, as well
as a grayscale variation.
What I'm trying to say is
that if you have a cosine,
two pi ux.
Its magnitude goes like this.
And its phase.
What is the phase?
What is the phase of the cosine?
What is the phase of a
positive real number?
What is the phase button?
Someone said zero here.
And that's correct.
What is the phase of a
negative real number?
Someone here suggesting zero.
Negative real number.
AUDIENCE: 180 degrees?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Fine, that's right.
So therefore, the
phase of the cosine
is zero, where the
cosine is positive,
and jumps to pi, where
the cosine is negative.
OK, so that would be a very
difficult transparency to make,
right?
Because you would have to
have the grayscale variation
like this to impose
the variation
the amplitude modulation.
And then you would have to
impose some variable phase
delay also, in order to
impose the phase delay.
So that is difficult to do.
But anyway, mathematically,
we can write anything we like.
So this is the cosine, and its
Fourier transform, of course,
consists of two delta functions.
So this is what these bright
dots indicate, delta functions
whose spacing equals the inverse
of the period of the cosine.
And, of course, if you
squeeze the cosine,
since the spacing
equals the period,
then the two delta functions
will go further away.
Another way to describe
the same is, of course,
by the scaling theorem.
If you squeeze, it's
equivalent to scaling
by a quantity larger than one.
And therefore, the
spacing will also
scale by a quantity
larger than one.
What is a more
physical transparency
that we saw in the
previous lecture?
I said that this
is difficult to do,
because you have to impose
both amplitude and phase
variation on the transparency.
AUDIENCE: A binary transparency?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: A
binary, that's right.
That's right.
If you add a transparency whose
magnitude looks like this.
Goes between zero and one.
That is fine, right?
I can do it very simply by
taking a piece of glass.
And I can deposit some
metal, for example, aluminum,
or chromium, or more something
like that in these regions.
Oops, so you can not
see what they were.
Yeah.
Sorry about that.
I pushed a button here that
I should not have pushed.
So in these regions where I have
the [INAUDIBLE] to the metal,
the transmissivity goes to zero.
Another transparency that we
saw, and it is also physical,
is this one.
That was actually the first
example that we did on Monday.
OK, how do I express
this transparency?
Is it cosine?
AUDIENCE: Is it 1/2
plus 1/2 cosine?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
Because it swings between
zero and one, right?
So this, this will do it.
Each Fourier
transform of this one.
How would it be different
than the Fourier
transform of the cosine that
I have on my slide here?
What is the Fourier
transform of this one?
AUDIENCE: So you
have a DC component.
You have a DC component,
and then yeah.
The magnitude of that
frequency is half of it.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So
in this representation,
I would still have the tool
delta functions at spacing.
But also in addition,
I would have
an extra spot in the center.
And this part would be brighter.
So the power that goes into
this part correspondingly
would be 1/2, 1/4, 1/4 squared.
So the spot that
goes into the center
is what you very correctly
refer to as the DC thermal.
And now, of course, we
know why we call it DC.
I think I mentioned
it also last time.
It's because it corresponds
to zero frequency.
So in electrical signals,
the zero frequency
is known as the direct
current, or DC, DC component.
OK, now without
cheating, that is
without looking at the
next page of the notes.
I would like to ask you, and
see if someone can guess.
If I rotate this
grating by some angle
what will happen to
the Fourier transform?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you rotate
it by 90 degrees,
I'd expect the frequencies to
rotate by 90 degrees, as well.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
So if you rotate
by 90 degrees, you
expect the two spots to appear
along the V-axis rather than
the U-axis.
If you rotate
somewhere in between,
where would this [INAUDIBLE] go?
They will also rotate
in what fashion?
OK, so the observation
to make here
is that the two
spots if you draw
a line that connects the
two Fourier delta functions.
These lines would be
perpendicular to the fringes
of the grating.
And this will remain true as
you rotate the grating then,
because actually, the
Fourier transform does not
know what the coordinates are.
So the Fourier transform knows
that you have a variation
along this direction.
And that gives rise
to the two delta
function in this direction.
In the vertical direction,
there's no variation.
So therefore, the
Fourier transform
is confined to the
zero frequency.
So if you rotate the
grating, then these spots
will rotate so that the
line connecting them
remains perpendicular
to the fringes.
This may not show quite right
because the projector actually
squeezes my slide.
So it may not show quite right.
But if you think about it,
you should convince yourselves
that the two spots
should be located
along a line perpendicular to
the grooves of this gradient.
And, of course, if you
squeeze the grooves
in this rotated grating,
then the two spots
will also move away,
again, along the same line
perpendicular to the grooves.
Any questions about that?
The other property of the
Fourier transform farm
which is listed in
the table of formulas
that they showed
earlier is linearity.
And linearity says that if
you have a function that
is the linear superposition
of two functions whose Fourier
transform you know, then
the Fourier transform
of this function is the linear
superposition of the two
Fourier transforms.
So for example,
here is a function
consisting of two gratings of
period lambda one and lambda
two.
Which one is the
Fourier transform?
That's the Fourier transform
of the long period, right?
Because the two spots
are close together.
If you take the Fourier
transform of the short period,
the Fourier transforms
are further apart.
If you do the superposition now.
What you get, well, it is a bit.
If you superimpose
two frequencies,
you get the bit pattern.
Here it is.
Looks kind of messy.
The Fourier transform
is relatively cleaner.
It is the two dots that
you get from this one,
plus the two dots that you
got from the other one.
So therefore, you
get four dots total.
That's what the
superposition theorem says.
Of course, you can generalize.
I don't know if you can
see in both of them.
On the top right here,
there's a bunch of dots.
These dots actually,
each one of those.
They're symmetrical
along the axis,
so therefore, they
correspond to sinusoids.
And the superposition
of sinusoids
looks very messy here.
It is still periodic, but messy.
Of course, if you look at
it in the Fourier domain,
each one of those
is it represented
by its own individual
pair of delta functions.
But, of course, this
is discrete now.
What is even more
interesting is that if you
were to connect all
these delta functions
and get the continuous
Fourier transform, then
your original pattern over
here, this page domain
would become nonperiodic.
So you can see very clearly.
Here, I have discrete--
a discrete Fourier
transform that corresponds
to periodic pattern.
AUDIENCE: Could you draw
the Fourier transform
in the overhead projector?
Because we can not see it.
It looks dark,
totally dark here.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
I cannot quite draw it, but
I can sort of cartoon it.
So the cartoon would
be dots like this.
Something like this.
So each pair of dots
corresponds to a cosine.
And then what you
see on the top left
is actually the superposition
of all of these cosines.
OK.
And, of course,
you can have sort
of more general transparencies.
You guys are too young
to remember this,
but about in 2006, I believe.
The Boston baseball
team beat the Yankees
After 85 or 86 years.
They finally managed
to beat them again.
And the night of the game,
this is the Prudential Tower.
For those of you who live
in Singapore, this is the--
I think it's the tallest
building in Boston.
And so that night, they lit
up their lights in the offices
in a way that if you
looked at the pattern,
you could see the sign,
Go Sox, the Boston famous
called Red Sox.
And, of course, the Fox
25 is the TV channel
that sponsored the match.
So I took a picture
with my camera.
I can see this tower from
where I used to live in Boston.
So this is a picture.
And if you represent
it as a transparency,
so that is the bright
spots correspond
to transmission of light.
The dark spots correspond
to blocking the light.
Then you can think
it's Fourier transform.
And you can see sort of
a more general pattern
that looks like this.
What is interesting is
that if you look carefully
at this pattern.
And I don't know if you
can see it in Boston.
But the pattern here
looks kind of diffuse.
But there's some distinct
spots, actually quite
a few of these spots.
Can anybody guess where
these spots came from?
AUDIENCE: Some of the
features in the image,
I guess, have straight lines
that kind of act like a box
function, but not completely.
Sorry, other way around.
You're seeing basically
periodic structure in the image
on the left gets reflected as
spots in the Fourier domain
on the right.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
The building has irregular
spacing between the windows.
So you see a very clear
periodic pattern here.
It is modulated by the
Go Sox illumination,
but nevertheless,
even the dark windows
are visible in the
picture, right?
Dark windows.
Some of the windows, they
turned on the lights,
some they didn't.
But still, you can
see the windows,
even if the lights were off.
So this gives rise to
a periodic pattern.
And, of course, the
Fourier transform
of a periodic pattern
as I said before is
a sequence of dots corresponding
to the Fourier series
coefficients.
So that's why you see this very
nice distinct dots over here.
It is the windows
in the high rise.
There's also more periodicity.
This is a roof that
also is periodic.
You can see a grating here.
can you still hear me?
I keep dropping
their microphone.
Thanks.
The grating here
should be visible as--
it must be one of
these pairs of dots
that do not correlate
with the building.
That is the pattern
on the roof over here.
This is a roof of
another building.
Now, let's look at
the various theorems.
I've already said
this before, so that's
the similarity theorem.
If you compare the Fourier
transform of two rectangles,
one small, one big.
The Fourier transform will
have the opposite behavior.
The small rectangle
will give rise
to a large Fourier transform.
The other one that
I wanted to describe
is this one, which
is the shift theorem.
So the shift theorem, we
briefly glanced over it
in the earlier slide.
So let me remind you what
this earlier slide said.
So the shift theorem
goes like this.
I will do [INAUDIBLE]
in one dimension only.
Then let's say that g of x has
a Fourier transform, G of u.
The question is now, if I shift
g of x by some amount, x0,
what is the Fourier transform?
OK, so we do the same thing.
We know that since this is true.
Since this is true, we
know that G of u equals--
then that is the definition
of the Fourier transform.
Now, the question
is what is this one?
So this one, the
Fourier transform
of the shifted function will be
given by something like this.
This, of course,
the same Fourier
transform, but now I plugged
in the shifted function.
And in order to
bring it to order,
again, I will do a
coordinate transform.
And this is very
easy because, again,
the bounds of the integral
are minus infinity, infinity.
They don't change upon
the transformation.
The integral doesn't
change either.
I mean, the differential
doesn't change either.
The only thing that
changes is here.
So you'll get the integral.
So x equals c plus x0, right?
Because this you recognize
is the same as this.
OK, so this is
the shift theorem.
So now, why is it
related to this one?
Well, this one, if I
do a cross section.
It will look like this.
What I did is I
drew a cross section
along the vertical axis.
So let's call the
vertical axis x.
So this is one.
What is this?
Well, this is a rectangle.
OK, we know this one.
And we computed this
Fourier transform.
If you look at this one,
it is also rectangle.
The size is the same.
If this is x0, this is also x0.
But it is displaced.
Let's use a symbol
for this displacement.
Let's call it a.
Actually, this would be minus a.
And this one.
OK.
So let's see if we can
apply the shift theorem.
Actually, we have to
apply two theorems here,
the shift theorem and
the scaling theorem.
Which one should I apply first?
OK, let me start.
Let's do one thing at a time.
So let me write
this function down.
So g of x equals.
Each one of those corresponds
to the three rects.
OK.
Now, I want to take
the Fourier transform.
So one, I've already done.
It's this one.
I guess I use the red pen.
This one, we concluded earlier.
It is x0, sinc of ux0.
What about the other one?
First of all, linearity
says that I can just
add them, right?
So that's easy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: They're going to
be the x0, sinc of u of x0.
But shifted by e to the i 2 pi,
a, and all that other stuff.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
So I will get this one for
this term times the shift
according to the shift theorem.
And similarly,
with a minus sign.
Because here, the shift is
in the negative direction.
I'm sorry.
The minus sign belongs here,
and the plus belongs here.
OK, so get a common
term in all of this.
OK, one is a plus.
That is a minus.
OK, so does this explain
now what you see here?
AUDIENCE: It's a 1 plus cosine.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's right.
This is.
And indeed, in this
calculated pattern.
Actually, the way I did this.
I used the fft2
function in Matlab.
And you can see
that fft2 correctly
produced as a
sinusoidal modulation
here, which is imposed by
the shift theorem, really.
So that's very interesting.
If you translate the
original function,
you get this
sinusoidal modulation
in the Fourier transform.
And now because we
have a superposition--
an interference, really--
of sinusoidal modulations,
that's why we'll get the--
well, these fringes in the
Fourier transform pattern.
And, of course, if you
rotate this pattern.
Then the fringes also
rotate by the same token
we said before, right?
Because now in this case, the
displacement is both x and y.
So you will get the
complex exponential
in the rotated case.
When you go to
the Fourier space,
due to the shift
theorem, you will
get the complex exponential
of the form, e to the minus i
two pi ax plus by.
Where, for example, this is a.
And this is b.
So when you do
this, a preposition
of these complex
exponentials, you
will get rotated fringes in
the Fourier transform pattern.
OK.
Any questions?
The last thing before
we quit for tonight,
or for this morning, is
the evolution theorem.
And that's a really,
really important one
that you probably remember.
I don't know, maybe you
remember it with horror.
Or maybe you remember
it with fondness.
But anyway, whatever
the case may be.
You may remember from
your systems classes.
So the convolution
theorem says that if you
have a system whose
input is g sub in of x,
and the output is g
sub out of x prime.
A linear system is
actually-- the output
is expressed as a convolution.
And you may be more familiar
with seeing these convolutions
in the time domain,
but it doesn't matter.
In the case of
optics, we're dealing
with space domain signals.
So we simply swap t with x.
But it's actually the same idea.
So one of the
[INAUDIBLE] example
of this convolution in the
case of Fresnel propagation.
If you remember,
Fresnel propagation
was g out of x prime,
y prime, proportional.
It had some additional
terms in front.
But the integral of that we
got goes something like this.
G sub in of x comma y.
So it is earlier convolution,
where this function, h of xy.
What is this again?
What is this physically?
AUDIENCE: It's a spherical wave.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Thank you.
So the convolution
here emphasize
that if you take Fourier
transforms of everybody.
So you Fourier
transform this one.
You call it G sub in of u.
You Fourier transform this one.
You call it G sub out of u.
OK.
Then the convolution theorem
says that this equals
G sub in of u times H of u.
OK, that's the
convolution theorem.
So it says that in
the space domain,
you have a convolution
relationship.
Then in the Fourier domain, you
simply get a multiplication.
And actually, that also
goes the other way around.
If you have a multiplication
in the space domain,
you have a convolution
in the frequency domain.
We'll get to use that
a little bit later.
Does anybody want
me to prove this?
Do you believe it,
or should I prove it?
Well, let me prove it.
Since we're in the
mood of a must today.
So let me write the
convolution integral.
Actually, before I do
that, let me write down
the Fourier transforms.
OK, similarly.
OK, so these are
really all the same.
Now, let me write the output.
OK, and by the same token, these
are the Fourier transforms.
I can also write the
Fourier integrals
in the inverse fashion.
So for example, I
can neither g sub
in of x equals integral G sub in
of u, e to the plus i two pi ux
du.
If you recall, we call this
the inverse Fourier transform,
or the Fourier integral.
And by the same
token, I have h of x
equals a similar looking
integral for H of u.
And g sub out, again,
similar looking integral
for G sub out of u.
OK, these are just definitions.
So far, I haven't
really done anything.
Now, let me write out
the convolution integral.
What I will do now is
a little bit horrible,
but you will see the
logic of it in a second.
I will substitute the
Fourier transform.
Actually, I'm sorry.
I will substitute
the Fourier integral
inside this relationship.
So how many integrals do I get?
I get three, right?
I get one that I had, and
then each one of those
will be written as an integral.
So here are the three integrals.
That's the original one.
Then for g sub in of x, I
substitute its own Fourier
integral.
And the same for h.
Have to be a little bit careful.
h is computed in this
shifted coordinate,
so it is x prime minus x du.
OK.
Now, what I'll do is assuming
that these functions are
well-behaved and
so on and so forth,
I will actually interchange
the order of integration.
Let's see if I can do it in
a way that it all fits here.
OK, let me be a little
bit more careful here.
[INAUDIBLE] variable, u is in
the same in the two integrals.
So to avoid confusion, I
will actually label them.
I will call this
u1, and this u2.
OK, so now, I have the
du1, du2 integrals.
What's inside g sub in of u1?
H of u2.
And all of this is
multiplied by a x integral.
So what do I have?
So for x, I have
u1 from this term,
and minus u2 from this term.
And what's left?
This thing left over, right?
So let me not forget it, e
to the i two pi u2 x prime.
x prime, of course,
is not plain.
So I'll just leave it there.
It is not plain in the
integration, that is.
OK.
So now, what is this?
I put one too many dx's.
So what is this?
It is the Fourier transform
of an exponential.
Remember, these
integrals without bounds,
they really go from minus
infinity to infinity, right?
So if I integrate an
exponential from minus infinity
to infinity, what do I get?
We said it earlier this morning.
Your tuition is ticking
away one second at a time.
Well, it's 9:25,
according to my clock.
So I guess we stop here.
And I'll let you ponder
this on your own.
See you on Monday.